[Music]
hey
everybody we're back in our normal
i was looking back i did look like
robert plant last night
somebody else somebody else commented on
the show that they thought that you were
dressed like um [ __ ]
what's his name the exercise guy
registered they thought you were just
like richard
yeah oh i just thought of something
funny
you should be slim good body i don't
know who that is you don't remember a
slim good body it was like from the 70s
or early 80s
he was like this guy was like a public
access show or something like that
and he like dressed in this like uh
once a year it was like a whole like
[ __ ]
whatever it was this whole suit but it
was like it was like his insides it had
like all his organs and [ __ ] on it
and he had i think i remember he kind of
had a little bit of a fro like not a bob
ross
level fro but kind of like a smaller
kind of fro
yeah i don't remember really yeah i mean
does anybody know
what i've been in brazil at that time
maybe maybe you work it doesn't even
ring a bell i mean
might have been late 70s or early 80s i
want to say because i remember seeing it
when i was a kid
yeah i went to brazil i think in 83 or
so
hmm unless it was just a local thing
i don't think it was though because i've
heard other people talking about it like
from other i think it like went out to
like all the pbs channels
so yeah and today is november first dia
di de los muertos yeah uh if you're but
it's i'm always like bummed out when
it's like the day after halloween
because halloween is my favorite holiday
and it's just always kind of like the
next day it's kind of like no it's over
yeah it's like i've even been like
watching like while i was working i
found on hulu they have like that
halloween baking show
yeah and it's like i love that [ __ ] i
love like i love watching people bake
cakes that look like haunted houses and
[ __ ] so i've been watching that like
because
to kind of get over my bummer-ness also
we're kind of doing some [ __ ] with
uh we just carved one jack-o-lantern and
the one that was in the background
yeah last night and he's uh roasting it
roast and pumpkin at the moment yeah and
then you're gonna
puree it and you're gonna make a curry
out of it yeah yeah it's gonna be
chicken pumpkin curry
yeah and it'd probably be something left
over to make a pumpkin cake or pumpkin
pie i mean
yeah you make pumpkin pie or we made
pumpkin bread last year
like i think we made three or four
loaves of pumpkin bread yeah pumpkin
bread's easy but we had two
real big pumpkins last year like this
year we just got like one
pretty good size one you know i have
that fruit-based dried fruit-based trail
mix with the chocolate thin there that'd
be good in a pumpkin bread
ooh it would wouldn't it with the fried
yeah it's got it's got dried cherries in
it and dried uh what what else is in
there dried cherries there was some kind
of nuts in there there was
several different kinds of nuts i think
it was blocks of semi-sweet
chocolate yeah that'd be good in that i
think that might be some raisins in it
is it cranberries and dried cranberries
yeah that probably would be good oh now
we should make some pumpkin bread and
throw that in there if we have any
leftovers you don't need a lot i think
you only need a cup or two right
like just for like one of those little
bitty looks like i made last year
but yeah so uh that's what we're doing
on the day after halloween recovering
um kind of sleepy because you know well
the time changed
too and then like pookie decided that
she was like why are you guys sleeping
and
i'm just gonna jump on your face all
night so that's why i woke up pretty
early they're asking will it be a
meatloaf recipe in the cookbook we were
just talking about the cookbook before
as we were waiting for the to get that
[ __ ] together for today's show
um yeah i could put i could put that in
i'm pretty sure that that's on the list
on the list yeah all right i got a good
i got a good meatloaf recipe
yeah he made real good meatloaf the
other day we still got some of it left i
think
yeah i think uh it's pretty standard
it's a pretty standard recipe but one of
the things i do is i'll take a bunch of
um
ketchup and i'll mix a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ] brown sugar in it to darken and
sweeten it
and paint that on the top of it before
you roast it and it kind of turns into
like a tomato glaze on the top
and then i serve it with um
apricot preserves or jam
real good put that on top of there
that's a mississippi [ __ ] there
it's like putting glaze on ham yeah yeah
it's real good
same kind of thing yeah i mean that's
not weird it's like that's like people
put
like honey glazes on hands yeah [ __ ]
like that so you can like you know it's
not weird people eat like
may uh lamb with mint jelly yeah it's
like that
i don't i just like lamb by itself yeah
but yeah so
uh carrying on the halloween we decided
we were gonna review
i was very excited to see this because i
hadn't heard any like pre
like chatter about this you know what i
mean i'm sure there was some but i
didn't hear it
so what ended up happening is that
shutter um as
most of you know had you know the uh the
resurgence the
of creep show like they did the newer
episodes what happened there were two
seasons right
yeah they were good too yeah they were
so i guess what ended up happening was
they were gonna do a third season but
then the pandemic and they couldn't get
all the [ __ ] together and like they
didn't have
uh you know the actors gonna come and
whatever so greg nicotero
decides he's like well we don't we're
not gonna have anything ready for
halloween and that sucks because that
was kind of what their plan was
so he had the brilliant idea he's like
well can we just do a one-off
creep show special that is animated
like so they don't have to worry about
having actors or anything like that
and he also got to adapt a story that
he'd been wanting to adapt since the
very first
uh you know creep show thing which was
the stephen king story survivor type
yeah it was a good story he's like we
optioned that for the first season of
creep show but it's like we uh
we ultimately couldn't do it because it
would have been you would have had to do
like location shooting because it was
like set on a deserted island and it's
like we didn't want a green screen and
like
that would look cheesy so he's like so i
was very excited that we finally got a
chance to do it because it was too
expensive for us to do like live action
so i thought that was really cool so
they decided to do survivor type to
stephen king story
and then they decided to do a joe hill
story so it's like a two-first like a
father and son
like twofer story and they're both
animated um i think this
animation studio is called octopi like
that's who they worked with
the animation on this is really nice it
kind of looks like
it's not like i guess it's not like
traditional animation because some of it
looks like comic book panels like it
would because it's creep show
but you know so some of it is just kind
of like the background moves and like
the person in the front like doesn't
move yeah it also looks 3d
yeah yeah and it's in layers it looks
good i mean visually it just looks like
a moving cartoon or a
moving comic book right it's very
striking yeah i liked it
yeah it ended up being really good and
um i didn't realize like while i was
watching it at the time but the
the um narrator of survivor type that
was kiefer sutherland
i knew that voice sounded familiar but
he was doing
he wasn't doing kiefer sutherland voice
he was doing kiefer sutherland
doing another voice so it's like because
i think he does a lot of voice work now
that i'm thinking about it
but it's like so after it i was like oh
yeah of course that's where i
knew that voice from um ultimately so
survivor type was the first one and then
the second one was the joe hills story
which was called
um i think it was called twittering from
the circus of the dead
now that short story that he wrote i
guess i haven't read that short story
but it was all done um in tweets
so that's the way the story was written
so they were like well
we wanted to adapt it but we didn't
really know how to adapt it like to a
visual medium because it's like we don't
just want animation of like somebody
just like reading [ __ ] tweets the
whole time
but i think they they struck a good
balance of that like where it's like
they kind of showed that and she's like
you know it's this girl who has kind of
like a very
whatever hashtag this is not like that
kind of yeah
she's like a really obnoxious she gets
hers though
well everyone does that's kind of the
whole thing of creep show is that if
they're like morality tales
um she couldn't get her face out of the
goddamn phone and kept [ __ ] [ __ ]
with twitter
as other people were getting killed
didn't think anything was real that she
eventually got eaten
yeah yeah when she got her alert
i liked that one because that that that
episode
or that story was really a big [ __ ] you
to twitter
it was it or to just to social media in
general
or you know to the fact that like people
have gotten like so ignored to
seeing things because what happens is
she's on this like road trip with her
family and she's like
whining about it the whole time like in
the car and they stop at this roadside
circus called the circus of the dead
and um ends up it's all zombies but it's
like
the way that she you know because
they're watching it for ages and like
they just think it's all fake
you know what i mean like these zombies
come out and they're like eating people
and they're just like oh realistic you
know
certain aspects of social media are not
good or not good for [ __ ] society if
you ask me
i mean twitter's one of them it's just a
damn rage mob
[ __ ] i don't like twitter i don't
even have a twitter but i hear
everything that comes out twitter
and it's just another but scandal after
scandal inflaming people and inflaming
people just dumb
dumb [ __ ] well i kind of thought it was
done when it first started but what's
dumb
is that even like the news channels pay
attention to it
[ __ ] what somebody says on twitter yeah
well you know
well that's what i mean i feel like i
don't feel like social media as
a thing is necessarily good or bad it's
all in how you use it just like anything
else just like anything else
well like the news channels are propping
up trying to prop up their
importance or their relevance they're
trying to use social media to prop up
their relevance well they're trying to
like
attract the utes yeah and they're trying
to remain relevant
when that news format is just [ __ ]
old you know i mean it's not relevant
anymore it'll be gone
eventually but okay so getting back to
creep show though i was kind of like
um i actually liked both the stories
were good um
obviously i was really happy to see an
adaptation of survivor type because i
thought nobody was ever gonna do that
just because of the you know location
and because it's like really really
gruesome
it's probably one of his most famous
short stories just because of how like
[ __ ] up and gruesome it is if you
don't know what it's about it's about a
surgeon
who he's taken a bunch of heroin
somewhere right like and then he there's
a he's on a ship
and it sinks and he ends up on this
island and then to survive he ends up
having to like eat himself piece by
piece yeah but like he's a surgeon so he
knows what he's doing and he has like a
bunch of heroin like to kill the pain
and whatnot
it's a classic story it really is like i
said and it's one of his most famous
ones a [ __ ] man i think it's like from
the late 70s or early 80s that story
um because i think he tried to get it
published like in magazines
and no one wanted it because they
thought it was too gross
um little did they know back then well
yeah i know it's like now it should be
people like you know what i mean a
person eating themselves yeah seeing it
but you know what i mean
um but at the time back then it was like
way too gory for people
i got admitted it was good to see an
animated version of it
that was probably probably the better
way to go i think if it was live action
it would have come off be kind of corny
yeah maybe but what's best about that
story is is is the written story it
reads
i remember that thing i haven't read it
forever yeah but i remember it was being
pretty engrossing
like you would get all into it because
it was all based it was from his from
his point of view and his his mom you
know yeah thinking about it
that was just i'm not sure that would
translate too well to live action but
maybe it would
it might not kind of like they're in
that same collection of stories there's
one called the jaunt
yeah remember that one yeah that was a
[ __ ] great read i don't think that
would make a good
short story yeah some of them it's like
kind of like
if you guys don't know what the jaunt
was just the idea was is that they
figured out how to teleport people
yeah across great distances but they but
they couldn't teleport you why you're
awake
if you were there was times when they
uh they teleported an animal while it
was awake and when it
arrived where when it arrived its
destination it would like be insane and
die
well the story's about a boy who's tried
to [ __ ]
he dodged he wanted to know what it was
like to teleport awake and he dodged the
sedative
to knock you out and uh when he appeared
on the other side he was insane going
it's forever in there remember
and yeah it was that was a good story
yeah it wasn't instantaneous it seemed
to take an eternity
right to arrive if you were awake yeah i
remember that story yeah that's
that made a fantastic read but i don't
think that would make a good movie
well like i said a lot of his stuff
we've talked about this a lot because a
lot of stephen king's stories because
he's like really good at like you know
detail work and characterization and
stuff
you can easily get sucked into a story
you can suspend your disbelief even when
he writes about crazy [ __ ]
but like sometimes when they adapt it
into a movie if they adapt it too
literally from the page
it just doesn't work the same like i
said that's kind of the same thing that
happened with [ __ ]
what was one of the shitty ones that i
was that was uh dream catcher
holy crap like which that book i
actually really liked
but i remember thinking when i was
reading it i just
like one particular part i was like dear
god i hope they never adapt this into a
movie because it's really gonna blow
and they did adapt it into a movie and
it did indeed blow
even though there was like really good
actors in it and [ __ ] like that but i'm
just like this is not
this is not a dab there's stuff in here
that like you shouldn't that's fine on
the page but you can't
yeah i mean ass weasels come on they
only kinda adapted the mist right
they i think they kind of got the tone
but they they [ __ ] up the end
i liked the end though the way they
ended the movie i didn't like i liked it
because it was like super bleak
yeah well wait a minute i thought it was
kind of oh they ended the movie
they killed themselves but then the army
came and saved them yeah that didn't
happen in the book
well no that he didn't they didn't um
the army didn't save him
there's just that one guy and he'd
killed his whole family
and then and then the army came so if he
had waited like
two minutes yeah that wasn't in the the
the the no
no the story didn't work there the army
never came
they just made it out of the they made
it out well the ending of the story was
ambiguous
right and you didn't know yeah there's
like hope
we don't get killed yeah i liked that
best yeah
because it meant that they hadn't been
saved from the mist they were still in
that alternate dimension and nothing was
going to stop it so there could have
been
future installations okay
but in the movie the army shut down the
experiment and saved everybody
yeah i didn't want to see that i wanted
to see the end of the damn world
i want the world to end god damn it
that's what made that story that's
actually a good point that it's like
yeah in a way maybe stephen king's
ending was bleaker because it was just
there was no
yeah hope of anything there was no hope
because throw down said cough the
langolier's [ __ ]
that's and you know what that sucks
because i really really liked that story
that was like creepy as [ __ ] it's like
think how creepy that would be to like
turn up to a [ __ ] airport like
nobody's there like all these people
like disappear off the plane
and it's like that seemed like such a
cool story and then when they made it
into a movie was that made for tv
it had a very made for tv kind of vibe
um
and yeah it just wasn't very successful
but
that said um i really i thought it was
really cool and i thought this was like
a good compromise that it's like look we
can't have a whole season of creep show
like in time for
halloween so let's just do this one off
animated special
and um you know and i liked that they
did like the stephen king joe hill
tag team type of thing that was really
cool i like the survivor type one
probably a lot better than the other one
but the other one was good too
um yeah i'm saying that the dark tower
movie sucked it sucked bad
well they tried it it didn't even suck
it was just like there
it was just like bland sucked and uh but
the
the books were great well they didn't
really adapt
any of the books they just kind of like
tried to
well they didn't make a story that was
kind of like the books
but not nothing like it yeah it was like
i just think that was a bad i mean
if you're gonna do that i think that you
need a series yeah
oh that could only make a mini series
you need to do a series with that
now here's the thing is that um
the the mandalorian is able to to record
still because disney bought that damn
nearly 360 degree studio have you seen
anything
it's like a digital yeah high definition
[ __ ] screen so you can put
them in an outside location and shoot it
yeah and while they're inside
and i think you're gonna see a lot of
that they said it reduced to the [ __ ]
costs a lot
and um the speed at which you could
produce like a high budget sci-fi flick
i really want to see season two but i
don't want to pay disney
yeah anybody have that on blu-ray you
can send it to me
somebody sent me a blu-ray the
mandalorian was that sophie sent me
blu-ray mandalorian i think it might
have been yeah there's a bootleg and it
looks like it's
came straight from disney we're gonna
get arrested it had
labels on it and credits and it had a
[ __ ]
it had the [ __ ] disney death star on
that [ __ ]
uh it looks like a disney factory
[ __ ] blu-ray
yeah yeah it's not though no bootleg as
hell
we'll end up seeing it look good though
i want to see it like i said i
i just recently like started subscribe
to hulu and uh
they have a disney disney plus add-on
but i don't know how much more it is a
month maybe like another five dollars or
something i think so
yeah i mean there's nothing on it but
the mandalorian that's the problem
yeah well i don't know yeah
i mean it's like disney's stupid for
trying to try to do their own but
everybody's trying to do they're trying
to do their own stream of service
they're [ __ ] stupid
they should have sold the mandalorian a
la carte through amazon they'd probably
make [ __ ] billions
yeah well what are you gonna do too late
now
somebody's asking about the tommy
knockers
tommy knockers the book was a mediocre
party tv adaptation
oh really i saw it i didn't well i
didn't like the tv adaptation but i
didn't really like the book either
it was all right but it wasn't one of
his better ones parts of the stories
about the aliens and the ufos and [ __ ]
and the weapons that they had looked
like round pizza cutters and stuff
that that that was kind of cool
but the rest of the book was just kind
of a jumble
of [ __ ] yeah i think he was just on some
good drugs that time i think [ __ ]
booze
well no he was on the bad drugs because
because when he's on
good drugs he writes good [ __ ] all right
that's on something it wasn't any good
i didn't like maximum overdrive it's um
it's one of those so bad it's good it's
fun but it's not
it's weird because the story that it's
based on is based on a short story
that's just called trucks
um the story is like not funny really
um not that i remember anyways but they
kind of made it into a comedy but i
don't know how intentional that was
i liked the um the book and the movie
what was the one about the guy who
who wrote uh fiction and [ __ ] his
fictional character came out of the damn
graveyard and was stalking him
who was that the dark half the dark half
yeah i really liked that book also i
liked the book the movie was okay
yeah the movie was decent yeah it's not
one that gets brought up a lot
yeah you know what i watched the other
day what's the name of that bad guy that
came to life
oh [ __ ] he was from jones county
mississippi yeah i just
watched that like a couple months ago
god damn it you guys don't know yes
my family comes from jones county
there's a movie about jones county
called the free
what they call the free state of jones
yeah and uh
about newt knight who was kind of like
our tribal leader back in the day
he fought the [ __ ] confederacy and
the [ __ ] union
you guys want to check it out [ __ ] my
dad descended from someone newt knight's
men
we knew we my dad was friends with some
of his descendants some of the knights
they're still running around
yeah yeah um i was going to say too that
a few days ago
or not a few days ago but like probably
a few weeks ago i rewatched
finner yeah which the book was really
good the movie's okay
yeah the movie was actually not as bad
as i remembered it
like i remembered it being like really
shitty but like when i rewatched it i'm
like
oh this isn't too bad this is like
pretty good like not it's it's kind of
like in the middle tier of stephen king
adaptations
you know what i mean yeah all right so
uh you ready you better go
you gotta check on that roasting pumpkin
we don't want it to over roast because
we make some [ __ ] curry out of that
[ __ ]
uh so yeah we will be back again
tomorrow with another live matinee
um we're either gonna review a series we
already watched or there's a couple new
movies that they've just added on
netflix and shutter that i wanted to
uh take a look at so uh we'll see what
what kind of [ __ ] we got going on when i
look at the [ __ ] tonight
so we will see you guys again tomorrow
and thanks for dropping by
bye